at a researcher at inside paris and also
at cardio ai lab
and he's going to talk today about his
work on selfish robustness
and equilibrium multiplayer bandits
thank you thanks thanks a lot
so yeah i'm going to speak about this
paper that i wrote with my student uh
a great president and uh as you say we
are focusing on a
multiplayer bandit so
the main motivation for this uh problem
usual motivation
is when you think about uh
opportunity spectrum access or
collective radio
so in this setting when you have your
own mobile phone you can
use sterile band frequency bands
and none of them are as good as the
other one
some of them are going to be very busy
because the
the user of this band is going to use it
you cannot access this band because
someone else is using it
and other bands are sometimes
[Music]
they have a high quality sometimes have
a bad quality
so the main the uh if we are looking at
this as a single single-player multi-arm
bandit problem we just the question will
boil down to finding the
the bands which has their highest
quality the more often
but the questionnaires in real life
there are certainly many many
many players agents using their
mobile phone at the same time and they
might interfere
again the question is can we define
protocols
algorithm such that the agent can learn
which are the best for the best
frequency without
interfering with each other because it
will lower the global
quality of signals so that was just the
the
motivation so just to remind you about
uh stochastic bandits
so just one slide very simple slide so
let's say that you have um
in single player mutant bandits let's
say that we
we have k arms just one rotation and
when the player is going to pull an arm
say armor one
is going to be a random variable so
either zero one one
and the value of this random variable x
one of t
is going to be a new one which is
obviously unknown
and the objectives of the the player as
as usual in minute is to maximize
his community reward so that's the easy
scenario scenario of medium bandits
and then we will have multiplayer bandit
so immediately abandoned we we have all
of those uh
arms that are available so the k arms
are still the um the k
frequency and we have m players that are
playing playing at the same time
they are choosing frequencies uh they
want to use
if uh they all use a different frequency
everything is fine
they do get each one of them get the the
reward assisted to their
choice so here player one gets x one of
t player two x two of t and player three
gets s4 of t
they are doing this independently
everything is fine
the uh the difficulty happens when
two of them are choosing the same arm so
for instance here in this case player
one and two through the same arm
and so they collide and uh the
idea is that when you if they were using
the same frequency
then they will the packets will be lost
and instead of being a a reward which is
potentially zero or potentially one x
effect x one of t would have been one
they get zero so if two players choose
the same arm at the same time the reward
is zero
instead of being x1 of t i know the
question
is before can we define algorithm
such that if each player follows this
algorithm
the the total reward is as big as it can
be
so just to summarize things we we have
m player putting harm at the same time
k arms i'm going to assume with that of
the generality that they are order by a
decreasing order so mu1 is the best
sound
due to the second best summons of us and
if the the regrets in social welfare
here's a difference between the maximal
expected reward that they could have
accumulated so far
all of us to get all of them together so
it's simply
uh t because t steps times the sum from
g equal one to m so that's the
first m uh best arm of the
muj the reward the expectation what arm
minus
oops oh minus the the cumulative stamp
of sorry of each player
and so here i'm missing the sum of a t
okay so the sum of the t and the sum are
all players of the other one
and i said before the reward is what you
expected
to be so if you if a player pulls
on k the reward is mu k if is the only
player
using this arm if there's two players
using mk
then the reward is zero because there is
a collision
okay so there is a lot of work
on this uh specific problem
stochastic case and in adversarial case
and
most of the approaches that exist right
now focus on either
the centralized case where you have one
meta agent that control
all the other agents or in the case of
copyright cooperative players
meaning that those players they all
follow the same protocol the same
algorithm
and their objective is to minimize the
global regrets
and what we ask ourselves in this in
this paper is
what about if we have uh in this
environment we have one player which is
a selfish
which plays for himself and doesn't care
about the other one
okay so he just wants to maximize his
own revenue and he doesn't care about
the straight wafer
it's probably uh right now it's probably
a good
good question to ask when uh we were
thinking about
those network frequencies and uh
probably there are some
some phones that are not playing by the
same rules and the other ones
anyway so the question is
if all the players are cooperative we
know what's going to happen more or less
but what happens if one of the players
is not playing the game and is trying to
to uh to manipulate the other runs the
other ones just for his own
interest so just to
give you a quick benchmark about this
problem what is the
difficulty what are the the
possibilities and what are the
the global objectives let's look at the
surprise case
the socialized case being again that
when you have one meta agent
that selects all the the arms pulled by
each agent
he controls everything and he sees
everything
so basically we have uh we this thing
boils down to a problem of a
single legend single multi multiplayer
mandates
with a command critical structure where
you have to choose
an arms amongst k since your this agent
is controlling everyone
you will not you will not collide on
purpose
so this algorithm will have no collision
and an optimal algorithm is actually
quite simple
so you have m choices for the first m
minus one
you pick the empirical best arms so far
and for the last one you do for instance
to ucb or any variant that you like
so this is a good algorithm because uh
the the choices of the m minus one best
arms
just gives you a finite regret it's not
difficult to show this that you're only
a finite number of times not going to be
among the one of those n minus one
actual base arm is not going to be
among the m minus one operator best one
of a number of times so here you get a
finite regret from this
and from the last one you can just use
the standard
kucb or ucbr techniques to show that the
regrets
is what you expect it to be and it's uh
the sum over uh
to this the difference between the uh
the um the expected
one divided by the k between those two
times lock t
so this is uh how the regret will
scale if you have one player that
controls everything
and that sees everything okay so
this quantity here in blue is basically
a benchmark
and the main question that we have in
this field
is can we achieve the same
regret the same growth of regret
with a fewer assumptions and just one
legend that controls everything
okay so we're going to assume that we
we we don't have just one player the
console everyone but we have
an independent player so this
uh uh either cooperative as usual
or they're going to be uh one of them is
going to be selfish in the future
but let's look at the first first thing
first let's look at the case where we
have a
cooperative player so in that case
the probably probably i'm saying foreign
because there is way of going around
this
there will be some collusion probably
so what we need to define
is you know in benedict is what is the
reward of your
of a player of an agent and what is is
feedback
and here there are many many different
possibilities
for the reward it's quite clear if at
stage t
you pick um k you get x k
of t that's that's a standard
and only if you are the only one
is this arms if someone else is using
this on that hour at the same time
there's a collision and you get zero
so your your what is x k of t it shows
the only
one using this term but now what is the
observation
so there are different cases the first
one is
the easiest one that we will call full
sensing you observe everything
so you observe xk so you know whether
you would have got
zero and one for this arm and you also
observe if there is a collision
so that's easy because you can always
estimate uk
irrespectively of the presence or
absence of the object
so that's easy that's a cool sensing and
the other way around
you have you know sensing no sensing
case where you just get to observe
your real world accuracy so it's
something which is between 0 and 1
so obviously if your reward is 1 it
means that
x k of t had to be one and there was no
collision
for sure but the the main difficulty is
if lk of t if your reward is zero you
don't know whether it's because it was a
bad arm so if mu k was small
or whether someone else was using this
arm and you had the collision
so that's the difficulty is knowing
whether it was
uh you know the zero that you observe is
due to
uh collision or to a bad arm
and there are intermediate settings such
as the one called statistical sensing
where here you get you observe you
always observe xk of t
okay so you always know whether you
would have got zero and one
but instead of observing the coefficient
you just get to observe
your reward so this is all of those
settings are motivated by different
practical application
and here's the difficulty in this
statistical sensing
you know that if you're uh if x k of t
is zero then your reward
is zero obviously but then you don't get
to see
if you got uh if there was collision or
not on the other hand
if x t of is one but your reward is zero
you get to see that there was a
collision and if your reward was one
obviously there was no collision
so in full sensing you always you can
always estimate your uh
your um the value uk and you get to know
if there was a collision
no sensing you never know if there was a
collision if there is zero
and in statistics something you don't go
you don't know if there was a
collision if x k is zero so it's
a different uh difficulty problem
okay so uh at least for the full fencing
and statistical sentencing
case and actually for other type of
fencing uh
feedbacks the standard one of the
standard technique
consists in emulating the socialized
case
thanks to a
communication trick so i'm going to
describe right right
so the standard algorithm most of the
algorithm that exists
uh are based on the following techniques
first things first
if you don't know m because maybe in
this game in this
in this setting we can assume that the
number of player m is unknown
and players are all anonymous
meaning that they don't have specific id
you can you can use a first
initialization phase
where you get to estimate m with very
high probability and each player gets a
different id
basically that's that's the the main
techniques and one of this player is
going to be the
leader and all of the player agrees
to which one of them is the leader and
then this feeder
will act as the meta
agent in the centralized case so you
will choose a surprise algorithm
and you will give to other players
recommendation on what they should do
and how does that work it's quite easy
actually
the thing is all players are going to
report to that
leader the statistics that this is that
they see so the number of
ones they see on each arms
and this leader is going to aggregate
all those statistics
make all the computation and i'm going
to be
to tell them you are going to use to
place this arm that arm and the tantrum
so to do that we need some communication
between the player
even though there was no communication
involved in the uh in the in the model
the way to do that is to tweak the model
actually and
to to collide on purpose so two players
can collide on the purpose just to send
a bit of information
so if i'm if i want to to send to shipra
because she'd just be
below me in zoom if i want to send her
one bit of information
i can just collide with her and just go
to the channel i know she's using i'm
going to go there
she's going to see a collision and this
means that i want to send her a one
on the other one on the other hand if i
want to send her a zero
i just don't go to her channel and she
will know that instead of sending
receiving a one
she'll receive a zero meaning that what
she gets this bit of
information so that's a trick
which is uh interesting
algorithmic speaking because it's
this communication it allows
communication and it's almost costless
the regret in cloud basis by these
techniques you can prove
that it's actually the order of logo
team square
so if you take all of those arguments
together
you can show that the regrets scale
as uh in the socialized case as soon as
you can observe collision
okay so in a full full sensing or in the
statistical sensing
you can more or less observe collisions
so you can recover uh
a regret growth which is exactly the
same one as in the surface case
okay and if we if you don't get to
observe the collision
you can trigger this this um this these
ideas with just a few more
assumptions and you can just get to
multiplicative factor by uh m
okay so that's actually quite important
but that's the idea okay if
you communicate with each other you
choose one leader you communicate this
leader gives recommendation to each
player
and each player follows the
recommendation of the visual
and this is quite this sentence is
actually quite important
i just say that everything is going to
work if each
of the agents follows exactly
the protocol meaning they do exactly
what the agent
the leader told them to do if they don't
do this everything follows apart
and this is exactly what will happen
with selfish player
so let's see at what is what would be a
good concept
of solution if we have a selfish player
so in game theory so i will use game
theoretical
concept i will assume that there is only
one player that is selfish
so here is going to be player j
and i want to look at a nash equilibrium
but epsilon nasher killer
meaning that a profile of strategy
of algorithm of player is going to be an
epsilon nash equilibrium
if each of those players if they unit
unilaterally deviates
they can gain at most epsilon okay
epsilon nash equilibrium meaning that
if you choose to not follow the protocol
and try to do something else
you can at most gate epsilon
and we are actually going to look at
so we have results for our epsilon
equilibrium and we are even going to
look at an
even stronger concept which we called
alpha silent stability
and the intuition is the following if a
player
aims at for some reason earthing the
other one
lowering the player of another player so
if player i
so if player j wants to reduce
the payoff of player i by by a constant
l
then it's on its own payoff will be
smaller
by alpha times l so if i'm if i'm trying
to hurt you for some reason
because i'm not a nice guy i want to
hurt you
on purpose uh you will see that i will
still have a cost to do that
okay so i want to to build protocol
algorithms which are
epsilon nash equilibrium so i cannot get
more than epsilon by deviating
and also stable in a sense that if i'm
hurting someone i will be earth in a
return
by a factor alpha okay
so that's the the idea
so obviously if you look at the existing
protocols they are not equivalent
otherwise this talk will be a pointless
and there are two reasons for this the
first one is that we are using
communication
so if two players are using
communication the selfish player can
interfere
he can interfere in the communication by
choosing not to communicate these
statistics
by improperly communicating statistics
by saying random random stuff
or he can also collide while others are
trying to communicate
so if i wanted to send ship zero and
stephan wants to uh to interfere in my
communication he can just collide with
ripa
and give and she will have the
impression that i told her one which
which i did not actually okay so the
selfish player can interfere in
communication
other thing is that if you want to have
epsilon nash equilibrium you need
for some reason that the algorithm is
fair
in the sense that a posteriori each of
the player gets the same
reward that's crucial because if one
player gets more
than the other one in that case would be
the leader because you know we get to
higher everyone the other one
then the selfish agent would want to be
will tweak the the algorithm so that he
becomes a leader
okay so uh we want to do this to build
uh
[Music]
protocols which are uh robust to this
kind of
of interference
so let's look at the first case easiest
case the statistical
sensing statistics sensing when you get
to observe the value of
a noun okay you always get to see this
and you also get to see your uh
your reward so you don't always see
whether there was a
collision or not if x is zero you don't
know if there was a collision but if x
is one you get to see if there is a
collision
the good the good thing is they can
always
[Music]
estimate the value of now the mean of a
number
so here are the thing is the technique
is quite simple
is we're going to have to ask each of
the uh
of the player to emulate the centralized
um algorithm by themselves independently
and how can you do that the thing is
well you have some
initiation phase that i don't really
care about
but during the exploration exploitation
phase
where the um the australia's algorithm
will ask
each of the agents of the emergent will
allocate one of the agents to each of
the
n minus one the best analytical arm and
the last one will
will play ucb or k ucb here what i'm
gonna do is instead of doing this at the
same time i'm going to do
this techniques this allocating
in over time so i'm going to play by
blocks
size m each agent you're going to play
by blocker size m and it's going to
to pull its minus 1 based on vehicle arm
in a shifted way
meaning that each one will start
at a different time modulo m and on the
last round
you follow ucb or kucb
and if each of the agents
have the same set of amplitude
arm which happen almost always but a
finite number of time
you can see that quite easily that there
is no collision
during the extra export phase and this
is obviously
an equilibrium because the
selfish player does not have that much
power because
there is no communication during this
phase there's no communication
between players so the the the
selfish player cannot interfere the
communication
and also the selfish player cannot
uh he could if he wants to try to use
other arms that he was supposed to do
during this so this explore expert phase
but since each of the player is going to
use one of the best empirical arms
if the the selfish player deviates
from the its algorithm
what is supposed to do is supposed to
pull the m1 which is the m
best amplification which was free so if
he's doing something different
then he will collide and if instead of
having a positive payoff he gets zero
so there is no way for him to increase
his payoff
so the only thing they can do is spare
his own regret because
as i haven't said the tribute is written
on the slide i assume
that this selfish program can know
everything
and this this super case they do that so
it's very simple it's very naive
they do that you we we have an epsilon
equilibrium
and also we have the advantability of
this parameter here
but the thing is the such good thing the
bad thing is that
it's very simple so it's uh it's
interesting like when you arrive
simplicity but if you like
working on your algorithm you might be a
bit disappointed
and the other bad thing is that you get
an extra factor m
in the ring rates compared to the
software's case so now the question that
we
want to ask is well can we get rid of
this factor m
and maybe in more difficult or easier
case
so the answer is sometimes we can and
sometimes we cannot
so if we don't have sensing if we if we
don't observe anything we don't just
observe
the reward then we can show that
there is no uh nash equilibrium
epsilon equivalent epsilon
negligible is such that the regret is
smaller than ort
this is impossible it's quite easy
actually you can just think of this
problem and say well if
the sensitive player knows everything
he's going to pick
the best arm and the other player will
have no way of knowing that there is
uh a selfish player that is always
repeatingly
putting the best arm and getting all the
revenue for himself
so that's quite that's quite trivial so
without sensing it's impossible
so now we can say well can we do
something with
full sensing on the other other way
around when you observe everything
can we get the regrets as
in in the socialized case so here it
should be reaching socialize regret so
can we achieve the same
regret as in surprise case and the
answer
is yes we can how can we do this
typically we want to do roughly the same
kind of
algorithm what we need to do is to have
a first stage of
initialization where each where we
estimate m
number of player each of this player
gets a rank
and not one but two leaders are design
then we're going to this define a new
robust communication scheme
and a new punishment through protocols
so the initialization is quite simple
basically the idea is to have two
leaders instead of one
why because if we have only one leader a
selfish agent will do whatever he wants
whatever it takes to be the leader
so here we're just going to assume that
we have two leaders we picked two lasers
and each of those leaders are going to
to make the same computation the same
signal
it's going to be everything the same
thing together and if at some point they
give
two different uh recommendations or if
they say two different things
we're going to raise the flag saying
someone is lying there is a selfish
agent somewhere
someone deviates from the protocol and
we're going to start a punishment phase
that's why we need two
uh two uh leaders instead of one
now the communication so we we as i told
you
selfish agents if you want the
communication the selfish agents could
interfere in the message
so here let's say that player j wants to
send a message to player i
and this message is just one and zero so
we will collide with player one
booster i and the first bits and then do
not collide for the remaining
steps so if there is a uh
um selfish adjustment the physician can
decide at some point to collide with
player i
and then instead of sending the the
message one and the zero
with the message receive a pillar i is
one some zeros then a one
somewhere and then zeros and so the
player i did not receive the message
player j was asking
so the way to get around this and get a
robust communication message is simply
quite simple is
asking play your eyes to repeat this
message just repeat the message they
adjacent you
in that case player i is going to send
the message i received one and there is
two ones this is message
and here the safety agent cannot do
anything because the only thing he could
do
is interfere again collide again and add
another one
so here uh player one the
selfish agent has no way of
avoiding getting caught and interfering
with the communication scheme
so this back and forth communication
scheme which is quite simple
allows robustness with respect to
a selfish agent and finally
the only thing that we need is a
punishment strategy
so if we notice that at some point
something was off
and an agent was clearly trying to
manipulate the protocol to get a higher
payoff so we know someone is
is of protocols we want to use the
so-called dream figure id in game theory
meaning that we're going to punish him
forever
until the end of time and how can we do
that
the thing is well we know that he's
going to try to
to pull one of the of the the arms to
increase his payoff so the idea is
trying to so we want to finish him
the first way to do that is each of the
players are going to support
each arms with a uniform probably just
trying to punish this player
but this is not enough because the
selfish player can still
get a higher revenue from this so this
is not a deterrent enough
punishment the thing is
it's likely that the selfish player is
going to
try to if he wants to uh
to deviate from the protocol it's in
order to sample
more often the best arm so the idea is
if we want to punish him
we will try to collide with him by
playing with a higher probability the
best arm
and this is what we do here because if
we try to estimate
uk let's say that we know the value of
this guy
because we don't know them but we can
estimate them we're going to sample mk
with the probability the higher
probability
the better k is uk is so
using this uh this scheme here
each of the player is going to uh trying
to collide with a selfish player
assuming that this guy is going to try
to uh to play when the best arm
uh more often that what he was supposed
to do and if you
do this if you play your arms with this
this is what
you can show so that's of some gamma
factor which is this one here
you can show that the the the gain of
the selfish player
can only be gamma times the average of
mu j
and this range of new j is what he would
have got had he
had he had he followed the protocol
so at the end he lost he has a relative
loss of one is gamma so he has a
constant factor loss
so this punishment is credible so
meaning that
the the selfish agent will lost more
by deviating than what he got by uh
trying to manipulate
the other agent and getting caught
and this is uh this is the the what we
see the techniques that we combine and
this is what we got to prove
that this algorithm uh achieved the
centralized regret
as you can see here in blue so
decentralized regret
and it's an epsilon nash equilibrium
and uh and it's also alpha stable with
some
parameters that we wanted that we
recompute
okay i don't know if i still have time
yes no
sorry i lost track of time there yeah i
was just thinking over this problem
uh yeah you are out of time yeah i'm out
of time
yeah yeah okay just just going to
conclude
saying that uh if the
the setting was
meaning that the agent have different
values for each arm you jk then uh
the objective is to find a machine that
maximizes the
the social welfare and there is a way to
adapt those algorithm
okay and to do that
i'm just going to go to at the end of
the slide okay so that's the last slide
we can achieve a small regret uh by
adapting all of those techniques
uh but i mean uh feel free to ask
questions
later on or read the paper and uh
that's it so just wanna say that the
upside of
of this paper is that we manage to
recover the centralized
uh regret even if there are uh selfish
players trying to
gain the the system and uh that's a good
thing
the bad thing is that everything
relies on this um very
specific protocols and i'm not sure that
they are well they can be applied in
uh for real for a real life foreign
application
but uh yeah that's it
thank you veneer i have one quick
question and then we can have like a
more general discussion about all
papers so so this is
if i understand correctly you assume one
selfish player right
or or can you extend it to like a few
i i guess you can extend it to constant
compared to m yeah
if you have if you have
a few players you can you can
you can still you can still um
[Music]
be robust to that the only thing is i
mean the main trick
is uh for instance in this case at the
beginning here
uh when i need uh two leaders it's
because i needed two leader because i
had one
uh selfish player if i have more than
one selfish player so if i have two
selfish players for instance and i'm
just using two leaders
they might they might agree to become
both of them
leaders and then do whatever they like
so if i have two little two selfish
players i need
three leaders
and uh and then the uh then and then i'm
trying to
yeah the the initial initialization
phase is going to be more costly but
that's going to be uh
just multiplied by the number of leader
i'm uh i'm putting in it
so yeah so you can do you think it's
scales
sorry yeah
and i was just asking like does it scale
expo like you are you thinking of like
selfish player being like logarithmic
of the total or can it be just some
i feel like it might not scale very well
with number of selfish players right
no i i think it doesn't yeah do not
scale very very well with this
number of players i agree with you
well for sure but it's always the case
you know in uh in um
in game story or you're when you have
more than one player that can mediate
everything becomes more complicated
because then
then the kansas can know like collide
and cooperate and
against so it's it becomes way more
like it is than just one right
but as i said you know it's that's a
good question if you have a collision or
if you have a collision
of uh of a selfish player a coalition of
selfish player
uh for instance all of the players that
are using the same provider
uh they might want to collide
and together and uh you know they screw
the other provider
so that's that's a that's a question
actually
thanks there were also some questions on
the q a
oh sure can you see them yeah you can
answer them
so i'll i'll just open the floor for for
uh discussion on all the three three
talks here and first of all i'd
like to thank all the street speakers it
was very interesting
um
enough and can you provide some
intuition about the case where
communication is delayed
okay so maybe just something that could
uh answer
offline right or buy or right
yeah you can just answer it in the chat
and maybe we'll just go ahead and let
people ask questions about all the three
papers
i have a few questions myself but i'll
wait and see first
if others have questions